bonjour hervé théry et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pour vous cette décision du juge de la
cour suprême d'annuler les condamnations
de lula est elle une surprise pour tout
le monde sauf qu'il faut un tout qui
peut relativiser c'est un des juges qui
a pris cette décision qui doit encore
être validé par l'ensemble du tribunal
et il ya condamnation n'est pas annuler
simplement il faut recommencer tout le
procès
à brasilia ce qui a été contesté c'est
pas la compétence absolue du tribunal et
coritiba c'est que ça doit avec ça
devrait juger ailleurs donc on
recommence tout mais comme ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps et que pendant ce
temps là lula est considéré comme
innocent de nouveau il redevient
exigeait donc c'est ça la grosse
différence que même si le il est
condamné à nouveau se fera sans doute
trop tard pour l'empêcher de se
présenter à l'élection 2022 parce que
vous faites bien le préciser c est un
jeune agent machine qui a pris cette
décision le tribunal de curitiba avait
donc condamné lula dans quatre procès
mais il n'est pas compétent pour viser
et juger ses affaires et elle vont être
présentés dans cette fois devant un
autre tribunal fédéral de brasilia mais
où le disiez en attendant de toute façon
ses droits politiques sont rétablis et
il peut se présenter s'il le souhaite
passagère voix sonar ou en 2022 en 2002
dans les derniers jours de 2022 pour
prendre ses fonctions au début 2003 donc
ça veut dire que la course était déjà
lancée il a elle change complètement les
les cartes sont redistribuées totalement
est-ce qu'on peut doit s'attendre à en
rebondissements judiciaires
c'est possible saint-laurent général
l'éveil à la cour est très divisée donc
il ya des initiatives sont parfois
suivis par les autres parfois pas réussi
a récemment nommé un juge extrêmement
conservateur qui peut aussi peser sur la
décision
donc on ne sait pas on a l'habitude de
dire en portugais que personne ne sait
ce qui se passe dans la tête d'un juge
ou d'une femme excusez moi le côté
machiste de la chose et donc
on ne sait pas juste pour donner une
note plus gaie le journal satirique
brésilien ce matin le sensationnaliste
décidé que sont prêtés en tout cas que
son équipe juridique va traduire en
justice la réalité parce qu'elle empêche
de faire son boulot en étant plus
étonnante que tout ce qui pourrait faire
comment est ce que cette nouvelle a été
prise par les brésiliens alors ça dépend
desquels puisque le pays est très
divisée donc les gens du pt et delà du
parti des travailleurs et la gauche en
général sont plutôt contents d'avoir un
champion de leur problème c'est que
depuis que brosse un arrêté là n'avait
pas d'opposition sérieuse n'avait pas de
nom à mettre en avant il y avait des
négociations un peu laborieuse pour
savoir si on pouvait faire un front de
gauche
mais si lula peut se présenter je pense
que personne n'aura le culot de se
présenter contre lui et donc ça veut
dire que la gauche aura un candidat
donc la gauche est très contente une
bosse marot avec sa stupidité habituel à
dicter mauvaise chose pour lui j'en suis
pas absolument persuadé parce qu'en fait
il a été élu par rejet du parti des
travailleurs est donc sauf s'il a déçu
beaucoup des gens qui avaient voté pour
lui la première fois il va de nouveau
avoir son d'épouvantail favoris en ligne
de mire et donc on s'achemine vers une
polarisation très forte entre les deux
géants du web sondage singe que vous
citiez disait 44 5 ans donc ça a l'air
de donner un avantage à lula mais en
tout cas beaucoup de gens qui
n'apprécient pas spécialement son action
et sa personnalité vont quand même le
soutenir par rejet viscéral du parti des
travailleurs
on peut parler donc dans revers pour
gerber o oui donc sur le moment oui
parce que ça ça lui met devant un
adversaire très fort devant lui mais
peut-être qu'en même temps ce ça va lui
servir d'épouvantail et resserrer les
rangs autour de lui même de gens qui
n'apprécient pas du tout son action en
général et en particulier dans la lutte
contre le coc vide merci beaucoup avait
atterri pour toutes ces précisions merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes géographe et
professeur à l'université de sao paulo